all right here's something uh I got to
show you maybe not quite as serious but
this account on Twitter called Daily
Loud tweeted a video uh that went very
viral 20 000 retweets 150 000 likes lots
of comments the caption of this video is
quote
incredible moment captured on video as a
shark takes an injured sea turtle to
humans on a boat so they can help save
it
then they posted the video of a shark
supposedly rescuing a sea turtle and
bringing it to humans on a boat to help
because it had like a rope around its
neck or something and uh let's just
let's play a little bit of this video
here so you can see it
oh my God look a shark is carrying a
turtle on the sea riding the wind in
waves after seeing human ships from afar
the shark worked hard to escort the
turtle over with the assistance of the
shark the turtle struggled to pounce
the discovery of sea turtles by humans
the shark turned around and left
gracefully the boy believes that the
turtle must need help when it actively
approaches humans the shark the turtle
out of the water seeing that so this
Turtle oh there he is you've got the
Rope tears of emotion originally the
turtle's necklace it's a racist attack
warm-hearted boy carefully examined the
turtle's wound just lightly stroked the
turtle's neck the turtle immediately
some Dolphins got him so this is
so that's what happened uh the the the
turtle was uh struggling in the water
the shark saw the turtle and then and
then saw the boat and said I got to do
something about this you know this poor
Turtle you know and I don't have and I
would take the Rope off but I only have
I only have fins and flippers so I can't
do it and and then the shark said oh
there's humans they have opposable
thumbs let me uh bring the shark over
and then he did
um now that video is I mean obviously I
hope I don't have to tell you is of
course totally fake
and they splice together two different
videos actually and and then edit it to
make it look like the shark brought the
turtle in for help when in reality in
the actual real world the fishermen
rescued the turtle from a shark that was
about to eat it that's what actually
happened which which by the way if that
doesn't make any sense and I don't like
these videos that you see like the real
video I I don't like either where you
see these videos of people they're
rescuing an animal from a predator
so the shark is gonna starve because you
happen to think that Turtles are cuter
or something you have this weird uh
hierarchy that you've established in
your own head about animals and so
you're going to take food away from the
shark
well if you're like me you probably have
a running list of books that you'd like
to read and maybe you have this list on
your phone or in the back of your
notebook I'll be honest I know I'm not
going to read uh all the books on the
list for me not even close which is why
I'm so grateful for short form short
form is the best way to learn the ideas
from all those books that you've been
wanting to read but haven't gotten
around to they make the best guides to
non-fiction books and their summaries
are incredibly detailed they give you
all the main info without all the fluff
and everything else they even offer
interactive exercises to help you apply
the ideas you just learned so you don't
forget them I use short form to help
cross some books off my list like the
life-changing magic of tidying up and
the power of fun which are some great
reads that I can't recommend enough and
look if you know me you know that A Book
Like The Power of fun that's one that I
have to read these books really helped
me unpack some deep traumas in my spirit
or this is your production team's way of
telling you to clean up after yourself
okay I get it to get a free trial and an
additional 25 off on annual
subscriptions join short form through my
exclusive Link at shortforum.com Walsh
or click the link in the description
that's short form.com slash Welsh
rescuing an animal from being eaten is
another way of saying that you're
forcing another animal to starve
or you're just ensuring that a different
animal will get eaten so you took that
food away from the shark he's just gonna
go eat some other animal that wouldn't
have died if you hadn't intervened
but that's not really the point
um my point is that thousands and
thousands of people actually took this
video seriously and they retweeted it
and left they're all these comments
saying oh my gosh that's so heartwarming
taking it at face value really believing
that a shark uh rescued a turtle
and this is the problem this is what
we're dealing with in society okay not
only are people incredibly gullible and
stupid and willing to believe anything I
mean I I and I think there's research
that shows us as well the decline in IQ
scores it's a real thing
uh idiocracy you know it is will go down
as one of the most prophetic works of
fiction probably ever made
and we are getting Dumber as we actually
are so it's not your imagination when
you look around and seems like wow
people are really stupid these days
you're not imagining it that's actually
happening and it's not just a phenomenon
online
if you go on the internet you you see it
you know you're able to encounter
stupidity but it doesn't just exist
there
so that's part of the problem is that
people are very stupid and will believe
anything
um
and then also adding to that is that in
our society we have this insanely
anthropomorphized disney-fied view of
animals we think of animals as these
rational creatures who engage in
reasoning like we do and have emotions
like we do and we can't wrap our heads
around the fact that that's that that's
not the case
um people are different we are distinct
and there's a reason why people have
civilizations and cities and art and
poetry and governments and you know even
if the left is trying to destroy all
that we still have all of that for now
and none of that exists among sharks or
pigeons or lions or you know dogs or
whatever
because we are we are different
and we can think that way so we will see
you know a struggling animal and we'll
say oh we want to I have to help that
animal
um other animals don't think that way
so just wanted to establish that it's
very important
and debunking a little bit of
misinformation is also I think an
important thing to do hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there